[Música]
avanzamos en directo américa con revista
de prensa con rosa pérez de rosa muy
buen día bienvenida vamos a hablar
entonces de el proxy tenemos tres
titulares empezamos con the gardian qué
va a pasar con el protocolo de irlanda
del norte y ya vamos desarrollando los
otros dos
exactamente raúl pues este periódico
británico the gardian hace una especie
de explain air para aclarar no de
ciertas preguntas que tienen británicos
europeos y el resto del mundo porque es
bien complejo el asunto básicamente en
un primer lugar the gardian pregunta
cuál ha sido el problema con el
protocolo de irlanda desde que empezó el
año no y para resumir lo que ya nos
comentaba esther herrera desde bruselas
pues y como hemos venido explicando el
problema está en donde se ponen las
aduanas después del break si no pues la
unión europea y reino unido acordaron
situarlas entre irlanda del norte y el
resto del reino unido en el mar de
irlanda para evitar precisamente una
frontera entre irlanda del norte e
irlanda recordemos irlanda del norte que
forma parte del reino unido e irlanda es
un estado soberano entonces precisamente
ahora el problema es que a pesar de que
irlanda del norte y el resto del reino
unido sea en el mismo país pues hay
ciertos obstáculos en importaciones y en
aduanas entonces el the gardian también
plantea que ofrece la unión europea y es
lo que iremos desarrollando a lo largo
del día de hoy la unión europea propone
una lista de excepciones para el
territorio del norte de irlanda que le
permitiera pues importar ciertos
productos sin tantas dificultades y por
otro lado pregunta también the gardian
el reino unido estará dispuesto a
aceptar estas propuestas de la unión
europea y aquí es el punto crítico que
nos comentaba externo el reino unido
quiere que la justicia europea no tenga
jurisprudencia sobre irlanda del norte
algo que de momento pues bruselas no
está dispuesto a aceptar porque dice si
todo si este territorio forma parte del
mercado común también debe estar sujeto
a las mismas normas así es rosa más un
tema que vamos a analizar con nuestro
primer invitado del día en 18 minutos
pero ahora vamos con tesón me miedos de
navidad estériles miedos para navidad
que tiene todos los británicos exactos
de sant es esta prensa más tabloide no
del reino unido que siempre acostumbraba
a titular más por la emoción y el
sentimiento y básicamente aquí pues este
es este miedo que pesa sobre el reino
unido al a raíz precisamente de todo
este problema de transporte que es
también consecuencia del break sino por
eso lo hemos querido destacar porque lo
que bueno está en portada de este
periódico es como el puerto de
felixstowe que es el principal de reino
unido según este periódico por ahí entra
el 40% de las importaciones al país está
colapsado porque precisamente la falta
de distribuidores la falta de
conductores de camión ha producido una
situación de colapso de acumulación sin
precedentes de contenedores en este
puerto y por lo tanto pues reino unido
está diciendo no podemos recibir ya más
mercancías por lo que las estanterías de
los supermercados y de las tiendas
podrían tener pues algunas carencias de
caranavi a vamos a mirar a otro
periódico esta vez como lo miran los
franceses con lemon reino unido se
mantiene firme en sus posiciones sobre
irlanda del norte así titula exacto pues
para también un punto de vista
europea europeo hemos querido ver como
este periódico francés no es crítica
reprocha un poco al reino unido que
ahora no quiera cumplir el acuerdo que
él mismo firmó no y reprocha exactamente
esto que comentábamos sobre la
jurisprudencia europea y como comentaba
esther se plantea si reino unido es un
aliado fiable no ahora que pues él no
quiere que los tribunales europeos
tengan jurisprudencia sobre irlanda del
norte y dice pues lo que comentábamos si
estamos todos dentro del mismo mercado
si esta región de reino unido está
dentro del mercado único tiene que estar
sujeta a las mismas normas seguimos en
europa rosa vamos a hablar ahora de la
extrema derecha en italia vamos con el
primer periódico el corriere de la sera'
fuerza nueva draghi están hablando del
primer ministro devalúa la disolución
por decreto el no de la liga rosa exacto
raúl este tema ha creado muchísimo
revuelo en europa que ya lo ha llevado
un poco menos pero lo que pasó para
resumir es que el sábado a raíz de una
manifestación contra la imposición del
pase sanitario a los trabajadores lo que
la prensa italiana califica de un grupo
de infiltrados de esta agrupación de
este partido neofascista fuerza nueva
pues irrumpieron entre otras cosas en
las instalaciones del principal
sindicato italiano la confederación
italiana de trabajadores pues
destruyendo las instalaciones como vemos
aquí en esta imagen y lo que sucedió es
que mario draghi el lunes visitó pues
este sindicato se reunió con maurizio
landini el secretario general que le
pidió que disolviera esta agrupación
fuerza nueva y mario draghi le respondió
que es algo que ya tenía en mente y que
se está planteando pues disolver
precisamente por decreto ahora bien el
problema es que sería la primera vez que
el gobierno italiano disuelve por
decreto una organización y esto pues
puede le da cierto miedo a mario draghi
y en ese mismo orden de idea está a la
vanguardia en españa' rosano exacto pues
en la vanguardia se hace eco de lo que
de lo que sucedió en italia como
distintos medios
europeos y básicamente pues
y analiza cuáles son los principales
obstáculos de esta potencial disolución
y es por un lado esto de que sería la
primera vez que se haga por decreto y
por otro lado los miedos de que esto
tenga repercusiones de cara este fin de
semana el viernes hay una manifestación
otra vez contra el pase sanitario y el
sábado una manifestación masiva
antifascista y pues tenía medio al
gobierno de que ya ciertas extensiones
rosa grasas gracias por todo este repaso
de la prensa internacional vamos ahora a
analizar nuestro tema el brasil con el
primer invitado del día
[Música]